hey what's up guys my name is shawn and
welcome back to my code review series
yes it is that time of month yet again
where you guys send me your code and i
take a look at it so how i usually pick
these is just based on if i think there
will be some value for you guys now a
couple episodes ago we actually took a
look at a ray tracing example i'll have
that video linked up there if you want
to check it out because today we are yet
again going to be taking a look at ray
tracing specifically an implementation
of something called ray tracing in a
weekend i mentioned this last time in
that rage racing video for those of you
who don't know it's basically like a
little website book thing that teaches
you like ray tracing in a weekend that's
kind of the idea now i did mention that
i would probably take a seat at some
point and do my own kind of ray tracing
in a weekend that is implement like the
ray tracing in a weekend try and improve
it and make it kind of like an
educational video series i am still
planning to do that but when i opened up
my emails today what i saw the very
first thing i saw actually this is
literally the most recent email there is
ray tracing in a weekend with i'm going
multi-threading in c
17 and i thought you guys would enjoy
taking a look at this as well so let's
take a look at this from valerio for
mato format
expecting his code to be well formatted
yeah that's that's pretty cool nice joke
hi china i'm a longtime fan of your
channel while cursing time zones prevent
me from watching most of your twitch
streams from italy i'm from italy i
don't think we've had an italian on the
channel review series or the code review
series just yet last weekend i had some
time in my hands i decided to try to
follow the ray racing weekend book
minutes inquiry yeah i will have that
linked by the way in the description
below the raid racing weekend thing
highly recommend you check it out if you
are interested in graphics i have to say
i had a blast see valerio certainly had
a blast so yeah 35 years old physicist
and while i'm not a professional coder
i've been working daily in school plus
for over 10 years maybe this technically
means i'm a coder nevertheless but only
recently i have become interested in
learning advanced and more modern cbos
plus so i take every chance i get to
practice i tried implementing the book
following my own style wherever i could
and as a bonus i've also thrown in some
multithreading just for fun i know
you're feeling on projects that don't
build out of the box these guys watch
the series so i've taken extra care to
take care of the dependencies either way
sub modules by liking cmf that's good
that's
good i'm expecting
a 35 year old physicist who's been
working in seattle's daily for over 10
years to get this right so fingers
crossed he has a cmake project but it
was created by visual studio sure i mean
i don't mind cmake projects so it should
work out of the box if you want to take
a look at it i would be immensely
honored you can find the code at this
and i will have this repository linked
in the description below as well keep up
the good work valerio
bacco
formatto the only thing i found
publishing during this build is linker
was able to find the d3d11 libraries out
of the box i guess they're already in
some defaulting path yeah if you install
visual studio with like the kind of
directx sdk which is usually included as
part of like some
simple plus for games distribution or
whatever it's i think it's just included
in them in the kind of standard visual
studio like msvc library so that would
explain why that is there a few things
that i like about this by the way and
why i've selected it for this video is
because this is a person who is
35 years old not 13
and i think that just the age of the
person can have a lot to do with what
the code is like now not necessarily i
don't want to be like ageist or
something here and say that yeah all 35
year olds are better than 13 year olds
no matter how many how much experience
they've had that's not true at all but i
think that maybe we'll see some
differences in the code compared to
someone who might be a little bit
younger just because that life
experience i think actually teaches you
to be a better programmer believe it or
not working daily in simplest for over
10 years interested in learning advanced
and more modern c plus plus i try to
implement the book following my own
style and as a bonus also thrown in some
multi-threading so these are all kind of
things that i think will make the code
interesting to look at hopefully we can
take a look at a more modern simple plus
example by someone who hopefully knows
what they're doing and i think we're
going to have a really good time with
this one but first
i want to mention this video is
sponsored by skillshare skillshare has
pretty much sponsored the entire code
review series this year so
let's just start off by giving them a
huge thank you for those of you who
don't know what skillshare is skillshare
is an amazing online learning community
where millions of creative and curious
people from all around the world can
come together into one place to learn a
new skill or skills because there's a
lot of stuff on that platform literally
like any topic you're interested in such
as illustration how to draw better
photography videography how to make
better youtube videos how to start on
youtube marketing productivity all of
that stuff skillshare literally has
thousands of classes to choose from and
they have an absolutely amazingly large
and high quality library available for
you to check out and these videos are
very efficient they're not like long
they're not youtube kind of you know
don't forget to hit subscribe and i need
my watch time no they're concise they're
to the point they're efficient and
they're gonna teach you those new skills
well and personally that's one of my
favorite things about the platform the
fact that it's just so efficient at
teaching skillshare is offering the
first 1000 people who click the link in
description below a one month free trial
of skillshare where you'll be able to
check out their entire range of classes
for free for a month so definitely give
it a go and sign up using that link i'm
sure you guys will find something there
that you are interested in
yeah it's just a great platform really
thanks to skillshare for sponsoring this
video all right valerio the physicist
let's see what you've got so we
mentioned that he would have a good
build process and
what do you know it works color me
impressed okay so we just have this kind
of kind of
weirdly
fades out i've clicked somewhere and now
this is
dead okay maybe things aren't going as
smoothly as i hoped let's hit start and
see what happens
my that is slow
why is it so slow it's rendering nothing
we're gonna see something oh some
spheres maybe
why is this so slow
and it's using
100
of my cpu cores
so it's using like 30 all 32 threads are
occupied here
and
it's running this slowly
rendering a few spheres
okay something's very wrong here well he
certainly wasn't lying about the
multi-threading that we can definitely
see but i'm just by the way this is
running in release mode just in case you
guys think i'm a fool okay we're gonna
come back to the performance this might
be a little performance episode would be
in line with optimization october even
though it's like december now let's take
a look at the code and we will
definitely circle back to that
performance because i am almost 100 sure
that i can make it faster okay so we
initialize this app uh pretty standard
stuff here let's see what this does
so he is using directx 11 in some way
possibly just for like the imgui
rendering and the actual presentation i
assume all the ray tracing is on cpu
side certainly with that performance and
that like core usage that we looked at
um let's take a look at this stuff so
he's using no discard which is a cool
little attribute it basically tries to
prevent us from discarding the result of
this function so that we don't kind of
call it as if it was a void function
which is fine throws a compiler warning
overall i like the neatness of the code
i like the m underscores for all the
private members here looks good to me
obviously very win32 dependent you've
got some directx backhand stuff all
pretty kind of boilerplate i probably
won't spend too much time looking i like
all of the directx 11 stuff because this
is all just boilerplate code to like
create like the device and the swap
chain and all the context kind of stuff
update texture 2d that is probably what
i expect is actually rendering onto the
screen which again is pretty standard
we're just mapping the memory there and
then doing a mem copy from the image
buffer which is where i assume the ray
tracing is writing into so we have like
a cpu side
uh image buffer over here which is
wrapped inside a unique pointer
interesting i probably wouldn't have
done it this way not a huge fan of like
wrapping because what's what this it
what this actually is if we take a look
at where it was created which i assume
is maybe okay it looks like it happens
over here create image buffer and then
you're really just doing an allocation
of just raw memory like this i would
probably make this like a vector so that
you could basically have like an array
that is the size of the size that you
need but on the heap if you're doing it
that way i don't know i just don't like
the idea of wrapping it in unique
pointer having a raw array wrapped in a
unique pointer you could of course just
yeah clank format that's cool using
clang format pretty nice um you could
just obviously have something like your
image buffer as a raw buffer like this
and then you could allocate it i may
have done it that way in hazel we have
like a class called buffer which
basically wraps exactly this and has a
lot of like convenience functions and
all of that it doesn't own the buffer of
memory so it won't delete it if that
stack object goes out of scope or
anything but it is like a wrapper over
that raw pointer to make things a little
bit safer and easier but i don't know
unique pointer for a
array basically for a raw kind of
allocated array what do you guys think
about that leave a comment below i
probably wouldn't do it as i mentioned i
would make this like a vector of un8t or
something like that and then resize it
to the appropriate size or maybe use a
raw pointer like this okay so we figured
out where the image buffer is the
renderer i'm assuming this is our big
boy who'll do all of the work so let's
take a look at the renderer class so we
have a bunch of render states ready
running finish stopped i'm assuming some
of these are probably necessary for like
multi-threading and maybe also
figuring out like when to update the
image and all that if it's still running
or not set samples per pixel and 500
okay well maybe that's why it's slow
let's try something a bit uh more
reasonable like 32 max ray depth 50 ray
depth bounces
50 bounces my gosh let's make this like
eight or something let's try it again
with these settings we'll see how much
this speeds up and then maybe we'll
actually see an image okay so let's hit
start now okay that's faster
but
when it gets to the spheres it's still
quite slow why is this taking so long
okay so a few notes about ray tracing
and all that i haven't actually looked
at the ray tracing in a weekend code i
don't
see why it would be this slow i mean
when it gets to like all the bounces and
there's multiple intersections because
you can see the reflection of the
spheres here i would expect it to be
slower but this is like this is insanely
slow and for some reason i doubt that
it's the ray tracing in a weekend code
so maybe you've done something weird i'm
this close to just dropping this code
review and turning this video into like
an optimization video should we wait for
this to complete there's a fair few
spheres around which is nice so the
image obviously looks quite noisy
because we made the samples so low one
thing i'd recommend though is maybe add
a denoiser to this i mean i'm i'm
assuming there's not a denoiser once
this finishes i just don't have the
patience to wait for this i think you
know what let's do it i'm going to wait
for this to finish rendering we'll see
how long it takes to render then we'll
see if we can do better by trying to
optimize it one thing i might do really
quickly is actually stop this from
taking over all the threads because i
need some like cores available to record
this video so let me just quickly uh go
into
let's see um the renderer how does this
render stuff we might as well look at
this so render a render that was a good
bet uh start rendering render state says
is
set to running
um what do we have here we have a lambda
we're going through this right pixel
above okay right pixel to buffer pixel
coordinate so it looks like we're
running we're writing pixels one by one
but assume this is spread across over
all the cores yep we have a thread pull
we add literally every single pixel
from image size y minus one
so that i guess is the top and then we
go so we go from the top to the bottom
instead of bottom top i guess which is
why we've got this reverse loop and then
we go through every horizontal pixel as
you saw there and we add this to thread
pool this i guess is the single threaded
version of this versus adding a task per
pixel not sure if i would separate every
pixel into a task but it is a thread
pool which obviously makes me assume you
haven't made
a hundred thousand threads um
so how do you make the thread pull so
thread pull just starts off there's the
pull
uh construct match okay thread count so
we're using this or we're using just
whatever's available i'm not sure which
well i guess we you were using the
default constructor let's just halve
this so that we use maybe half of the
cause this will obviously slow it down
but it will mean that i can hopefully
record the video as well now that i
think about it i hope that
those sections when i was running it um
with all the cores actually recorded
okay to be honest it doesn't even look
like it's slowed it down that much
but we should now
be utilizing half of this stuff so you
can see our usage is like 78 77 it's not
a hundred percent so we're obviously not
occupying everything
uh with this ray tracing app cool all
right well let's just run this for a
while see how long it takes
and uh
i hope you print out the time that it
took let me just quickly check that out
okay logger debug rendering took and
then we've got a stop time minus start
time okay good so in other words we
should actually see
how long this takes when it's done
whenever that is
okay
it's done
455 seconds that's seven and a half
minutes to render this frame at 32
samples with all this noise
at this resolution which is what like
1280 by 720 i think i could have written
a ray tracer in that time all right guys
throw this code review out the window
we're gonna fix this back at it again
with channel fixes your code
okay so
again i don't know what is going on here
but i just know from experience that
that is way too long so there has to be
something wrong here so let's talk about
how we might approach optimizing this
what i'm gonna do is just a really quick
scan over the code first of all there is
not that much stuff going on um you know
there's very like array tracer is most
is mostly just mathematical functions
like normalize square root reflect you
know that that's really all there is to
a ray tracer there should not be
anything else really going on apart from
the mathematics and i think it's really
really important that you don't try and
over engineer
the language side of things because
that's really easy to do you could get
lost with all of simpleplus's features
he didn't mention he was using superhero
17 he gave his own personal style to
this whatever that means we're about to
find out what that means but my initial
fear is that something here is slightly
over engineered because the physical
mathematics here i don't think that it's
possible for the actual mathematics that
need to be done to take that long like i
would expect that frame to
well definitely not over a minute like
that is wild so let's take a look at
what's going on here okay so um
dielectric scatter and that is what this
is a material dielectric okay so we have
dielectric materials public material
okay so the first thing that i'm not
really potentially liking here is the
whole virtual function
uh
class hierarchy situation why is that an
issue for performance because the
problem is that i'm sure that he's got a
bunch of different materials let's see
what else is here metal
lamb version as well scatter and they've
all got scatter functions so per pixel
immediately when we look up a material
it's not as simple as just deciding what
it is we need to do we need to also make
sure that we dynamically dispatch that
to the right function using a v table
now again fundamentally not the slowest
thing in the world however when you're
writing a ray tracer you have to realize
that you are processing each and every
pixel one by one whether that be across
different cores i don't care you're
still going through each and every pixel
on the cpu and you're running some kind
of code over that
to make matters worse what happens when
the ray bounces well you have to do you
have to cast another array somewhere
else so potentially multiple bounces
obviously per pixel i think we're doing
like eight there could be other stuff
going on such as lights and shadows like
there is a lot of stuff that happens
like these functions are very hot in the
sense that they get called so much and
because they get called so much we need
to be careful with things like memory
layout and like what what what it is we
actually do per pixel because that's
really really important and so
immediately i don't like the whole
dynamic dispatch kind of i don't like
the whole like inheritance v table
situation here because that is
definitely going to be slowing things
down at this scale
now
um you've also got an optional here
which isn't the worst thing in the world
but probably will require some
additional processing at some point i
could imagine some cycles being wasted
there the other big problem by the way
with having virtual kind of classes like
this and the whole v table thing is that
you kind of can't really have them be
tightly packed in memory anymore like
they become and and we'll see in a
minute i might be wrong but i'm pretty
sure this means that you're also heap
allocating each and every one of these
materials which again i think for a
material is fine
but um
yeah let's see what the sphere situation
is because that looks like you're on the
object here you've got a hittable object
list
which is has a hit function
hittable object
and a sphere maybe a sphere is a sphere
is a hittable object
and then you do hit on that
so where does that get called from hit
object hit hittable object list
hit
and then this is all of the objects
probably in the scene
so we have a scene filled with objects
and then we
run hit on it shoot ray
so we should array out
per bounce as well and then we try and
call that hit function which will
obviously go through
all the objects which are all spheres
all on the heap or somewhere else in
memory
and then try and figure out if it hits
them or not
so from a memory kind of fragmentation
cpu cache situation this is this is far
from ideal and i think again at this
scale that matters so much and i'm
probably about to prove it to you to be
honest but we'll see let's not get ahead
of ourselves so i think i kind of
understand how this works i just want to
look at the renderer one more time so
when we do the renderer so what we do is
we go through and we use scd accumulate
which again goes through begin and end
samples which we have samples per pixel
so we have basically 32 of these that
we've made initialized to zero that's
not too bad we're running over 32 of
these
um but then
we go through and then we shoot rays
which if it hits something we use the
material so we look up the material to
see how we should basically scatter that
ray how we should proceed with that ray
and then we run shoot ray again and we
use scene.hit
and scene what's seen seen as a hittable
object
which is probably that hittable objects
list
how do we so how do we add stuff
scenes.cpp that's useful how do we add
stuff to the scene here so if we're a
default scene
then we take scene and m scene is a
hittable object list okay so we have
that scene and then we add and yeah you
can see all of these spheres are make
shared right you're using a lot of heap
allocated memory here every sphere is
somewhere else in memory
i would not do this
what i would do is i would prioritize as
much as possible to try and keep this
scene as cache coherent as possible i
want it to be in contiguous memory right
next to each other i want these to be
stack allocated objects right this
hittable object list should not contain
a vector of shared pointers it should
contain a vector of these actual
hittable objects which again might be
difficult because they're all kind of
virtual and very object oriented so
you have to remember
with ray tracing with these mathematical
algorithms you need to prioritize the
math and the data that is all that needs
to be calculated you are basically
getting your cpu to do a bunch of
mathematical calculations they should be
as streamlined as physically possible
they should not be spread across memory
like this so that's i'm not sure how
much of a performance impact that's
having but my bet is it's definitely
going to be noticeable right we'll keep
going and we'll we'll see what we can do
okay so scenes are composed of all of
these kind of uh spheres i guess you
have a bunch of random i guess okay i
guess this is just a bunch of random
sphere materials and spheres are
randomly placed as well you have some
glass stuff you have three materials
here so three i don't know which scene
we're actually running
uh let's see m scene type is default
scene so it is in fact this first one
okay sure so again you're creating the
scene up and then the renderer will
eventually go through that scene and
shoot all these rays it will go to scene
hit we know scene is that hittable
object list so that will then once again
seduce
i'm not exactly sure why you're using
std accumulate here i am not very
familiar with this function um but this
to me
at the moment is kind of screaming out
over engineering like
what i assume accumulator is doing is
you're just passing in this kind of
lambda here and it will call this for
each object in this range and then
accumulate or sum up the values that's
what i think is happening
i would write this as a for loop
because i think that would both make
more sense and also
will probably avoid like a lot of the
overhead but i'm not exactly sure again
how that's all gonna work but i do see
what you mean by you've kind of updated
it more using all of these library
features again optional accumulate i
probably wouldn't use any of these to be
honest because what it's doing is it's
adding a little bit too much abstraction
for my liking to the actual mathematics
and the actual data which is exactly
where we should be prioritizing
this entire code base okay so now that
i'm more or less familiar with the code
let's go ahead and launch the
performance profiler so we're going to
target cpu usage hit start again we're
in release mode let's hit start and i'm
going to let it run for a little bit
especially over these spheres and i'm
really interested in seeing exactly
where that cpu time is actually going so
if we go back here hit stop collection
let's see if we can select a range that
was after we actually hit start which is
this section over here we've got a
decent amount like 10 seconds here of
sample data let's take a look at what's
going on and it looks like there is no
source information available why are you
not like
compiling with debug symbols or
something or release
let's take a look at like link uh
debugging
generate debug info no maybe this is for
like some performance optimization but
let's just enable that
and then let's also just double check
here
that i have no idea where this is
debug information format yeah let's just
set that to like c7 and i'll go ahead
and make sure that's done for the render
this is a static library so it's not
going to have those linker settings but
debug information format c7 compatible
and i think app as well i'm not sure if
we're going through app or if that's a
different program but just in case i'll
set it all to c7 compatible let's go
ahead and close this session
and then we can just go debug and
relaunch performance profiler okay so
i've hit start hopefully we'll actually
get some debug symbols going here all
right that's enough let's hit stop
collection i'm not sure if you can hear
my computer struggling with this but my
goodness
networking 98
why okay so let's take a look at this so
this is the hot path 86 51 percent again
it's all so render issue ray is taking
97 that's what i would expect from a ray
tracer let's take a look though at what
exactly is going on so there's all of
our source information
uh okay attenuation let's just expand
that hot path and we'll see what's going
on scd accumulates
35 percent is spent here
and yet
so this is fear hit this is the
mathematics
and these are all
like below 0.2 percent of total time
the in fact this is 0.76 percent
but this is 35
what is going on
reduce up
so that's the function that's the
templated function we're passing in so
that's this lambda
which what does that lambda do object
hit
yeah which is sphere hit
and this is an if statement that's the
return statement that's getting that
optional value
how
how is the
where is all the performance going
what
i don't understand this at all i'll be
completely honest
i'm not sure how 35 of our time can be
here
what's first what's so we're
dereferencing first we're passing in a
value
u first is uh
all right okay so that's the
that must be let's go back to here that
must be um
[Music]
the actual object that we're running
over so that must be the sphere
yeah there it is because it's that
parameter in the lambda as well
okay i
don't know why accumulator is so slow
but
here's what we're going to do the
problem with this the problem that i
don't like is that again this is
redirecting to some other code that
obviously we didn't write
and furthermore is using this kind of
lambda which again goes here but it's
just it's a little bit weird like
this lambda it's not showing me the
actual details of the lambda for some
reason so in other words it's not it's
not showing me what part here is slow
because again i don't really see what's
going on like i don't see why any of
this would be so slow
but let's let's try and rewrite this as
a for loop
because i want to actually see
the profiler tell me what part of the
for loop is slower rather than just
being like yeah it's this whole
accumulate accumulate lambda thing
because again i honestly do not know why
this is so slow
so where was that slow thing
um std accumulate this is what file is
this hittable object list probably yeah
hittable object list so let's go to
hittable object list
and let's go ahead and rewrite this so
how would we rewrite this um well first
of all i want to do this in such a way
that we can easily go back to the other
implementation so we can test the
difference between them
um so let's go ahead and copy this
and okay so how would we do this well
we'd go we start off and i'm going to
write this in as simple of a format as
possible so i'm going to i'm not going
to use a range based for loop again i'm
trying to make this
uh as simple as possible i've got that
clang format thing
i'm trying to make this as simple as
humanly possible right because this
should be all kind of line by line so we
can see if retrieving some kind of
memory is being slow like what is taking
up all this time that's what i'm
interested in so we'll go through all
this so we need to get the object so
let's say
okay so what is the type the type is an
std shed point again i'm going to write
all of this stuff out so this is going
to be a const reference of this hittable
object we'll call it
object because it's this thing so const
order is what we're taking in so we've
basically duplicated this here i could
have made this order but i'm trying to
be explicit so objects i so we have the
object and now we just need to do this
so if temp hit then object
object hit and then return so return
temp hit
um
[Music]
so closest so far equals the value
return temp hit oh that's that's what
we're accumulating i guess
what are we accumulating
city optional here so this is probably
the initial value so let's start off the
initial value
record
and then
let's do
hit record return temp value and what's
a hit record all of this stuff is that
face normal okay so okay so if we've hit
something closer i guess we can just set
record equal to temp hit
otherwise it's going to be temp value
which was the first parameter that we
took in which would have just been
whatever we set it to last time okay so
i think we don't even need that okay so
if i'm not mistaken if we hit something
closer than the other thing then we
overwrite the value basically with this
and we keep track of what is the closest
so far by keeping track of the distance
of that ray to the thing that it hit and
again if it's closer then we override it
otherwise we don't we just keep it and
then i guess at the end we just return
well we returned this so at the end i
guess we would just return this record
over here so let's return that
and then let's get rid of all of this
okay that looks pretty reasonable to me
let's just run it to make sure that like
it works i guess
and then we'll see
whoa
look at how fast it's running
what
does this look the same as the other
thing have i made a mistake
look at how fast that is
23 seconds
what happened
how is that 23 seconds
is that should i take a screenshot like
before or not it looks the same doesn't
it what on earth let's quickly run a
profile over that
what
i mean i have never used a cd
accumulator before like ever
i don't think
i've come across it but i've never
actually written it before
is it really that slow is there a bug in
this msvc library or something
what's going on why is it so fast now
and that's not even this is still
running on half my cause
but look at this so where are we
spending the time in now
hit a [ __ ] list hit still
okay so object hit is taking up 32
percent as you would expect and then
let's just expand that hot path sphere
hit okay this is this looks better so
you can see that we're actually okay so
some of this optional stuff might be
slowing us down a little bit you can see
it's taking like three percent maybe i
wouldn't use optional as well but you
can see that we're more or less inside
this function now because
we can see that we're calling hit and
it's being called and again those
samples this is a sampling profiler most
of those samples 30 are ending up within
this function
right and then the rest by the way are
probably also ending up within that
function but in a different stack frame
so really they're all ending up within
that sphere hit function which is again
what you would expect now to take this a
little bit further
i wouldn't use
uh
optionals here at all
right because what you're doing is
you're saying that in certain cases
right let's just return
like an optional with no value and then
that way obviously back here we can use
that uh
if statement that we had here right well
we're still using it here we can use
this if statement to determine that it
was not hit so therefore
you know whatever let's not update the
record and you know because there was
something that was closer i guess or
whatever or it just didn't work out so
we return optional here we return
optional here as well find the nearest
route lies in the acceptable range sure
i probably wouldn't do that and then
also you're creating a hit record here
and then you're returning it packaged
inside an optional what i would probably
do is
basically bring out like a hit record
like this
maybe set some kind of like default
value for t like minus one or something
um
this returns an optional that's fine
because obviously this isn't per pixel
or whatever i assume well this is per
object maybe this would be maybe we
don't want to return an optional here as
well but if we did we probably could
just check t if it's negative one let's
return
you know a blank optional however you
even do that which i guess is well you
did that before so it's just this
otherwise we'll return that record or
something like that and then we'll pass
this record as the kind of uh you know
target of this hit so that way we don't
have to create a hit record copy it do
all of that stuff it's already within
this stack frame and then also it means
that we uh you know we don't need to
return optionals or do anything like
that which seems to be taking up some
some of the uh profiling cycles that we
can see over here right we don't have to
waste all that time doing this stuff
um because we can obviously just uh you
know we can just well return i guess we
can make this a void function and it
would write everything into that hit
record that we actually pass in and in
this case just not write anything
right because that's effectively what's
happening anyway
so
we could definitely and then we wouldn't
need any if statements because this
function would be the one doing the work
because i i guess from another kind of
code like looking through this code and
this algorithm another thing i don't
like is you've got a bunch of if
statements for stuff here but then
you're doing it again here
so then you're checking this if right
these if's should almost in my mind be
enough to say okay don't write anything
in here so therefore we don't need
branches within this function and other
branches outside of the function at this
level because that's just like
that's just a bit unnecessary
so there's still a lot we could do um
that's not even to mention the whole
shared pointer situation
um because again i wouldn't use shared
pointers okay so this code review is
already dragging on but let me know what
you guys think of all of these proposals
if you want to see me implement this and
take this project as an example and try
and make it as fast as possible remove
the shared pointers remove all this
optional stuff maybe see how much
performance i can squeeze out let me
know in the comment section below i will
make an additional video where i go
through and try and optimize this
specifically maybe this code review
series is going to become an
optimization series but let me know what
you think of that because otherwise i
know that maybe not everyone's
interested in the optimization part of
this and also i think we've got some
pretty good pretty decent gains if you
know what i'm talking about i mean we
went from like uh seven and a half
minutes to 20 seconds so i don't even
know how like
i don't even know how that's possible
let's maybe restore this to like what it
was before so this was an scd optional
let's hit f5 but yeah that's like i mean
this still i think could probably be
optimized a bit more it is still in my
mind taking a considerable amount of
time probably for the reasons that i've
mentioned there's just a lot of like
shared pointers and
memory all over the place but 22 seconds
man from seven and a half minutes
with half of using only half the threads
because i've still got like the divided
by two there i think that's decent okay
so let's let's quickly wrap up this code
review we'll see what else we missed and
what we have to look at um again there's
not even that much stuff going on here i
just like to summarize i don't like the
object-oriented nature of this i think
it's a little bit also over engineered
in some areas
i think that um i mean
you know you've got like 10 years of
experience as you mentioned with this
the code itself is very
well organized you you definitely like
you know you've made an effort to make
it good
but i think again and you know there's
exceptions and all of this stuff which
is fine like in the uh compared to some
of the other stuff exceptions are fine
i'll forgive you for that
because that's obviously more of a
personal opinion anyway
um everything looks really clean uh
maybe some more comments regarding some
things would be good
um but to be honest like this is pretty
standard this is like you're making a
projection matrix basically
and setting up the camera
um this is totally fine okay so you've
got you're using some randomly kind of
generated uh rays as well uh which is
again pretty typical to be honest most
of this is in fact math not sure why
you're using scd instead of glm here i
don't know maybe it's faster or
something in some cases but i would
expect you to use glm probably
everywhere
um yeah i don't really have too much to
say i mean all of this stuff is is
pretty
decent like again i don't have any um
negative feedback about the actual code
style or the way you've written this i
think it's nice but i would kind of
reduce it a little bit more to be like
you know kind of closer to the metal so
to speak i would kind of reduce some of
the abstraction and the fluff and the
kind of hierarchies of object-oriented
objects and uh you know heap allocations
with like smart pointers and optionals
and like i would reduce all of that
stuff i would kind of focus it more on
the math
and focus it more on the memory and the
way that the cpu is processing this i
mean honestly like i like this code i
would i would be happy to take this
maybe i'll do it myself with the ray
tracing in a weekend series that i was
talking about but um i think this is a
great case study for how we can take
some over engineered code that is
running slowly as we saw and make it as
quick as possible the other thing that
would be cool to do as always is to use
a gpu to do all of this computation
because that's obviously going to be
much much faster and you won't have to
manage some kind of thread pull with
only like even on my computer 32 kind of
threads running you could have like
thousands on the gpu running in like
fragment shaders or compute shaders
right that could be that could 100 be
done and that would be way way way
faster so that could be another way that
you could obviously extend this this is
i'm getting motivated hearing myself
like explain all of this now i want to
write like some kind of gpu based very
very fast ray tracer ah but anyway hope
you guys enjoy another tracing code
review let me know what you guys thought
about all of that but of course i think
the way that we looked at this compared
to the other ray tracer that we looked
at was very different so i hope that
this was helpful for you guys hope you
guys enjoyed this video if you did
please don't forget to hit the like
button below as always you can send in
your code to cherno review
there will be some instructions in the
description below whatever it is you're
working on if it is interesting if you
need some help if you think it'll be a
good learning example or you want some
guidance as well feel free to send it in
i do get a lot of emails as i mentioned
but who knows you might just be the one
thanks for watching guys don't forget to
check out skillshare using the link in
description below and i will see you
next time goodbye
[Music]
you